Hello guys, Chris here. Welcome back to
another Sunday video. In this one, my
friends, I'm going to be testing a
GeForce RTX
5060, which is an 8 gigabyte GPU. Like
seriously, Nvidia, let me remind you
guys of something. Two years ago in
2023, the RTX 4060 released and I, as
well as many other reviewers, said that
its 8 GB of VRAM would become a problem
in the near future and that that GPU
should have had 12 or at least 10 GB of
VRAM. And well, Nvidia had a great
opportunity to give us back the 12 GB of
VRAM on the 60 tier GPUs that they gave
us four years ago with the RTX 3060.
Yes, because the 3060 for some reason
had 12 GB and the 4060 has eight and the
5060 now has eight as well. So, this is
releasing in 2025 and many of the games
that I'll try in today's video already
need to be scaled down a little bit in
terms of texture resolution to
accommodate for that pitiful 8 GB frame
buffer. But moving on from that, let's
talk about its specs now and see what
improved over the 4060. So, the new RTX
5060 is based on the Blackwell
architecture. It features
3,840 CUDA corores, which is actually a
decent improvement over the 4060s
30072. It's 25% improvement. It also
features 120 TMUs, 48 drops, those 8 GB
of GDDR7 VRAM, not GDDR6, but again,
size matters more. a 128 bit memory buzz
which is the same as the 4060 PCI
Express 5.0* 8 which looks very funny
here. It's very small on this Gigabyte
card. The Windforce two times the PCB in
fact is super short as you can see here
in these shots. And finally, a 145 watt
TDP, which is above the 115 watts of the
RTX 4060, but it still pretty much sips
power, you know, considering today's
standards at least. Finally, it comes in
at
$299 MSRP, and it can actually be found
for MSRP in many places, including here
in Portugal. So, that's great, I guess.
But that doesn't mean you should buy it.
Let's play some games on it and see what
the RTX 5060 can do in its year of
release
2025, shall we? And first up, we got
Cyberpunk
2077. This looking beautiful at the
1080p resolution using the ultra
settings preset without resolution
scaling and without these options right
here. Just depth of fields and motion
blurs. Everything else is set to the
ultra preset and we're getting 90 to 100
FPS which is pretty good especially
given that the RTX 4060 under the same
scenario here in same settings got
around 20 less frames per second. So
that's quite a big difference there.
Goodbye Bob. I bet Bob actually designed
this GPU to only give it 8 GB of VRAM.
Yeah, he's a demon, by the way. And we
all know that 8 GB of VRAM should take
no place in a GPU in 2025. That's a big
shame. This GPU could have been quite a
bit better if it had like 10 or 12 GB uh
in some of the other titles that we'll
test here today and it would give it
longevity, right? But with 8 gigs, it's
very hard to recommend even though the
performance is actually pretty good as
you can see here. Let's make it a little
bit better looking. Not by enabling rate
tracing, but by enabling DLEA with that
new transformer model. This makes the
game look so much sharper, but it
actually makes it run like an RTX 4060.
Obviously, 4060 with the LAA would also
perform a lot slower uh into the 50s and
40s. This one is now into the 70s. I'm
not sure if it will drop at this point,
but the graphics are so much cleaner
here using the Transformer model in DAA.
I really like this and I think I would
prefer to play the game like this. Let's
see if it drops from 60. 62 frames
there. Okay, we need to get rid of Bob
once again. Is my car still there by the
way? Parked. Nope. Not not really.
Goodbye Bob. Okay, there we go.
Beautiful Bob kill right there with a
blood streak on the ground. And um nice.
Apparently it gets 69 frames per second
on average. This is their car by the
way. They haven't noticed. Oh, they
noticed now. Anyway, 69 FPS average is
very nice indeed. And it doesn't drop
from 60 fps. So, the LAA is where it's
at, my friends. I would use these
settings if I was playing with this GPU
as my main card for sure. But what about
that rate tracing? Well, let's use the
rate tracing ultra preset, which enables
everything over here, aside from path
racing, of course. And let's try it with
DLSS quality first. and ray
reconstruction as well. This makes it
look a lot better. Let's use like 50%
sharpness there on DLSS. And I'll also
disable these options, the motion blurs.
Okay, here we have it, guys. This is
looking really good. I can see that
there's a little bit more shimmering
here and there because of DLSS quality,
especially under reflections. Is ray
reconstruction enabled? No. Okay, so
that's why. All right, with this
enabled, yeah, definitely looks a lot
better. Okay. Um, you know what? If you
want to play with some rate racing, this
is pretty decent of an experience. Still
60 plus all of the time, which is a bit
impressive considering it is the rate
racing ultra preset here. And quality,
the LSS with ray reconstruction looks
really good. It's not as sharp obviously
as the LAA was previously on ultra
settings, but it is arguably sharper
than
TAA. However, we're seeing a bit of
stuttering here and there already, guys.
So, if you want to use rate tracing,
which is very intensive, not only on the
core of the GPU as well as CPU, it's
also very intensive on VRAMm. And that's
what happened there with those couple of
spikes. the VRAM maxed out. It swapped
into the RAM. So, um, yeah, we're not
even at fullon 1080p resolution. This is
DLSS quality, so it's rendering at 720p
and upscaling to 1080p. And we're
already running out of VRAM. That is a
big shame. If only this card had 10 GB
or 12 GB of VRAM, it would have made
such a big difference, guys. Oh, but
what about some frame generation? And I
almost forgot about that frame gen
consumes even more VRAMm. This card
needed a bit more VRAM even to take
advantage of these new technologies like
frame generation or multiframe
generation. Like right now it's actually
a really smooth experience. I can't
count the 1% lows by the way because of
how the new frame pacing technology
works with these cards. Uh but this is
two times frame gen. It looks good. It's
actually really smooth right now. But
that VRAMm is filling up quickly. As you
can see, it's actually touched 8 GB
already. Once we go to Bob's roundabout,
I think we're going to see exactly the
same problems as before, right? Yep.
There we go. Stuttering. It's a little
bit worse than it was before because now
we're adding FG on top of everything.
So, yeah, from time to time it will need
to use more VRAMm. It will swap some
things that should be on VRAM to RAM and
it will stutter a bit more. It could
have been a buttery smooth experience
here with frame generation if only the
card had a couple more gigabytes. And if
you're wondering, four times frame
generation consumes about the same VRAM.
Uh, and it looks like this 200 almost
200 FPS 170s 160s here. But the thing
is, yeah, I can feel I can see the
jittering happening because of that
VRAMm limitation. Like, it's very
apparent right
now. Next up is an esports title,
Counter Strike 2. We're playing at 1080p
using very high settings with two times
MSAA. Here we go, guys. Nvidia AWP is
being utilized here. You see the the
stickers there? Hello. Okay. Hello.
Goodbye. Goodbye. Let's start counting
our FPS. 300s 100% GPU utilization.
Obviously, this game is more CPUbound
than GPU bound. So, I needed to make
things uh taxing for GPU. That's why
we're playing with Boom. Hello there.
What the hell? I thought you went to the
other side.
Okay. All right. But yeah, for this to
be a GPU bound scenario, we needed to
use very high settings. Even though not
a lot of people play with very high
settings, including myself. I usually
play this on low uh in a CPU bounce
scenario.
He just spawned there. How is that fair?
But uh yeah, it works absolutely
flawlessly obviously as it should on a
5060. And since it is an esports title,
8 GB is actually adequate for these
kinds of games. Uh still not adequate
for a 2025 GPU that Elastigador again. I
want to believe that El Castigador is
Bob and we will get our revenge.
Okay, come on. More of you. Wait. Hey,
it was him. He killed us again. No way.
We got to get these
bobbster. Not him. Not him. Is that him?
Nope. Come on. Come on. Where are they?
Where are they? Hello. Too many angles.
I prefer this two.
Okay. Okay. More. More. Okay. Still
didn't get Bob. Is it you, Bob?
No. Where did you come from, you
bastard? Come on. Is that you? Yes. We
got him. We got him. With 3 seconds
remaining, we got Elastic. We got Bob.
Yeah. F you, Bob. Next up is The Last of
Us Part Two Remastered. We're playing at
1080p using DA with DLSS4 and the max
settings here aside from motion blur and
these pesky little things over here.
Okay, so right away we're starting here
with 69 FPS. That's a good sign because
all we want really is 69 FPS all of the
time in all games. If it could do 69 FPS
max settings in every game, I would be
very happy actually. But there is
something that is worrying me a little
bit guys and that is that VR RAM
consumption. It's allocating 7.8
gigabytes almost. And I think this is
this might not be enough for very high
textures at 1080p resolution. At least
when I tested the RTX 4060 in this game.
It's also an 8 GB GPU. on very high
textures in a different scenario to this
one. It was struggling quite a bit and
dropping a lot of FPS because of the
lack of VRAMm. And I think in some
scenarios at least it will end up
happening with this one as well.
Actually, let's just test it out here in
another area. Okay, closer to 100 frames
per second. So much less intensive than
that forest area. Little bit of a frame
time spike there, but you know, could be
just a one-off. Uh the VR Oh boy. Okay.
No, definitely. Yeah, it happened, guys.
This This is not normal anymore. Okay.
And that's classic VRM bottleneck
scenario there. So, yeah, you should
probably stick to high textures at
least. So, I'm going to leave everything
else on maximum settings and just going
to select the texture quality on high
over here. All right. So, here we are
again with high textures this time.
Hopefully, this stays smooth all of the
time. VRAM allocation is still pretty
high, but the RAM usage is a little bit
lower than it was before. So, it was 16
something GB previously. Now, it's about
a gigabyte lower apparently. And uh it
was right here, right, where we started
seeing some frame time spikes. And oh,
this still
happens. So, we're just going to have to
set it down to high preset. Okay. And
lower down a ton of different settings
here. So even though the GPU itself had
the power to run it on very high
settings, it doesn't have the VRAM
unfortunately and that ends up happening
in extreme situations where a lot of
VRAM is required. So here we are now on
high settings. It still looks pretty
nice, of course. Like there's not that
big of a difference between high and
very high, but this time around we're
not seeing those little spikes in the
frame time graph anymore. Well, there's
one of them there. But uh turning this
corner and actually aiming at the
peoples here, everything is absolutely
fine aside from a little spike that
happened. But uh yeah, much more stable.
The VRAMm allocation still really high
though, but that RAM usage is definitely
lower, which means that it actually
swapped some things previously on high
textures um and very high settings
everywhere else. So this is the way to
play this game. absolutely buttery
smoothly. Select the high preset. And
now let's go back to this area. Pretty
intensive on the GPU. We started with 69
FPS previously. Now it's closer to 100
frames per second on high settings. So
obviously this is going to be buttery
smooth 100% of the time. Again,
unfortunately you can't really max it
out because of VRAMm, but hey, you're
not really losing that much in terms of
the visuals here. Next up is a gorgeous
game from a few years ago that still
looks amazing and doesn't have VRAM
related issues. It's Red Dead Redemption
2 at 1080p ultra settings. The LSS says
ultra quality there because I went into
the Nvidia app and enabled the LAA to
replace the LSS here and it's also the
LSS4 and this makes the game look way
better. It's the best anti-aliasing
possible in Red Dead 2. And I made a
couple of adjustments right here. The
reflection MSAA set to two times, not
maxed out. Water physics is also set to
one notch over there. And the tree
desellation is disabled. This gives us a
really good visual fidelity, guys, and
pretty good FPS at the same time at
1080p resolution. It looks glorious
right now. Let's start counting our FPS.
And I mean, it's such a night and day
difference comparing DAA in this game to
TAA, which was the previous only
available option basically, aside from
if you wanted to utilize like FSR. This
changes the game in my opinion. It makes
everything look really sharp and you do
lose a little bit of performance
comparing to TA. You know, about 10
frames per second lower here, but it's
so worth it in my opinion. Uh, I'm I
think I'm a little bit lost, guys. This
is not where I wanted to go, but at
least we can see it drop from 70 fps
here. Okay, very dense forest areas.
We'll drop it to 69 frames per second.
Very nice. Uh, but we need to kill Bob.
Where is that bastard? I think it's in
this direction, maybe. Ah, here we have
it. There's Bob. Okay, let's do this,
Roach. Grab Bob and get out of here.
Let's go. Sing for us, Bob.
sing going through bushes and
everything. This is amazing. Very nice
vocal cords right there, my friends. Bob
is such a good singer, isn't he? Let's
keep on going. Is he dead? Maybe. Nope.
No. Still singing. Still singing. This
is the oldtime radio, my friends. You
know, back then there weren't any cars.
There weren't any radios. So you had Bob
singing with a lasso. Beautiful, right?
Anyway, 60s something FPS. It's dropping
to like 65 minimums here in Strawberry
Town, which is one of the most intensive
towns in the game. Uh sometimes in Saint
Deny at night, FPS tend to drop by a
couple of more frames. Like what the
heck? Why did you do that, Roach? But
yeah, that means that worst case
scenario, it will drop to like 60 61 62
frames per second. and that is
absolutely amazing of an experience in
Red Dead Redemption 2. It does a good
job and it's with the LAA enabled as
well. So, can't complain in this one.
Okay, so next up is Call of Duty War
Zone, guys. And this is just a warm-up.
Okay, let's just try to hit some people
so I don't seem too bad when I die
instantly when I'm playing the game.
Look at these textures, right? Yes.
That's because even though we're playing
at 1080p ultra settings, this is the
ultra preset with NIS native just to
sharpen the image. I had to set the
texture resolution down to very low for
it not to stutter. Even on low, it was
having some little spikes from time to
time. So, uh, yeah, and I mean, in this
case, it's probably something to do with
game optimization and resource
allocation rather than having 8 GB of
VRAM because other versions of this
game, earlier seasons especially, did
run fine on normal textures with an 8 GB
GPU. But now, yeah, very low is the way
if you want the smoothest experience
ever. Obviously, most people playing
this game will also play on low settings
coupled with very low textures. So, uh,
that's fine for visibility and
competitive play, but, uh, yeah, if you
want visual fidelity, ultra settings,
you got to deal with low resolution
textures if you want a smooth
experience, of course. And who doesn't
want a smooth experience, right? Anyway,
that aside, this is actually a really
smooth experience. 133 FPS average feels
amazing. Of course, it's high refresh
rate even on ultra settings. Oh, we can
go here. Okay. All right. Can I snipe
people from up here? This is what most
people do in Call of Duty War Zone,
right? They just stand still with the
sniper rifle looking at things. Hello.
This is boring,
guys. Somebody died here. We're close to
enemies. There's one
there. Come
on.
No.
No. God damn it.
Oh, this is awful. This is awful. Okay.
Okay. I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm
fine. Okay. Finally got a kill, guys.
Finally got a kill, but I'm out of Yes.
the armor. Now, our first Unreal Engine
5 entry here in this video is Stalker 2
at 1080p using the high settings preset
with DLA and no frame generation at the
moment. And here we're getting close to
60 FPS, although a bit under it here in
this settlement area, which is really
intensive by the way. And it has Bob as
well. Where is he? There he is. Goodbye,
Bob. There we go. Okay, so let's move on
from here. Let's get out, please,
without dying. Okay, let's heal
ourselves as well. There we go. All
good. The frame times are a bit
unstable, but that's completely normal
from a Hue5 title, which this is
obviously, and it's not well optimized
whatsoever. But yeah, it's all right.
It's an okay experience like this, but I
think things can improve quite a bit
just by adding a little bit of frame
generation in this game because this is
one of those games where the frame times
are a bit inconsistent, but if you
enable FG, they actually become a bit
flatter. So, let's do that. So, here we
go. Frame generation is now enabled and
we're getting 100 FPS instead of those
uh 60 fps that we were seeing before or
70s. This is actually really decent in
terms of the input lag. Surprisingly,
it's better than I expected. This game
doesn't feel that great even without
frame generation. In terms of input lag,
but here enabling reflex and FG still
makes it really playable in my opinion.
Also, another plus of using frame
generation over DAA and not over like
DLSS quality is that you still keep the
sharpish visuals from the LAA here in
this one. Yeah, it's smooth. It's
stable. VRAM is enough in this one. No
problems there. And we get 100 FPS with
the frame generation enabled. It's a
little bit of a shame though that it
doesn't sustain 60 all over the time
without FG's help, but still it's not
the end of the world since it works
quite well in this title. Now, it's the
super well optimized Forza Horizon 5 at
1080p using TAA and the extreme graphics
settings, maxed out settings actually,
aside from the textures over here, which
are set to ultra because of our 8 GB of
VRAM. Now, that doesn't really matter
too much at all, actually, because uh
ultra textures or extreme textures look
pretty much the same in this game, and
you're usually driving at high speeds,
not paying attention or licking walls uh
to see those textures, right? And here
we can have really high FPS, as you can
see, 120 fps at native 1080p. TA is a
bit blurry, but it's actually one of the
best, if not the best, implementation of
the tech that I have seen so far. And
here we go. Look at that. We're going
really fast, guys. We slowed down a
little bit because we hit that ledge
there, but uh yeah, 130s looking back at
it. 120s. All right. Okay. No license
plate loss. So, we still have that GT710
for the win there. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
[Music]
Yeah. Okay. All right. Well, we hit
Bob's house over there. Come on. All
right. We're arriving at the city
almost. Uh, no more green grass, by the
way. I don't like that too much.
Everything is super brown right now
because it's probably summer, I guess,
or autumn. It's probably summer. Okay,
let's keep on going here. Dropping down
into the lower 100s inside of the big
city area. Not bad whatsoever, but this
is still not the most intensive thing
that you can do in this game. That is
going inside of this tunnel and actually
getting out of this tunnel. So inside of
the tunnel itself 90s and getting out of
the tunnel getting 86 frames per second.
That's the absolute minimum. So
basically this translates into a high
refresh rate experience all of the time
and it's a gorgeous one at the same
time. And uh it's nice. Okay. Very
smooth indeed. Next is the extremely
intensive Allen Wake 2 at 1080p DLA. No
frame gen at the moment using the high
settings preset. Not maxed out. A lot of
things are still on medium. As you can
see, this is just the preset without
rate tracing enabled either. And even
with these settings, again, not maxed
out, no rate tracing, it's not enough to
achieve 60 frames per second. This
saddens me a little bit cuz I thought it
was going to get 6070 maybe with these
settings. It's nothing special, right?
Again, not maxed out, no rate racing.
Yet, this is the best the 5060 can do.
Yeah, it's not it's not impressive
whatsoever in Alan Wake 2,
unfortunately, guys. Let's stop it there
and let's try some upscaling first. So,
quality LSS in this game actually works
really well. This is the new Transformer
version as well. It looks just a little
bit blurriier than native resolution at
1080p. So, that's very impressive since
this is 720p resolution basically at the
moment. Uh yet, it looks so damn good.
So, this is a way you can play at 60
plus FPS all over the time without
losing much in terms of visual fidelity.
And I'd argue it's almost the same. Once
again, if you're not seeing things side
by side, you could say that this is
actually native 1080p. So, very
impressive stuff from the LSS4 in this
one. But what if you want to stay with
the native resolution and maybe add a
little bit of frame generation? Will
that work properly or will it be super
input laggy? Let's find out. two times
frame generation with
DA8 might actually be running out of
VRAM. I don't know. Probably not,
actually. It was probably just applying.
So, right now, I can't really count the
FPS cuz 1% lows are going to be crap
because of the new frame pacing. But, it
is very smooth in terms of uh the just
the smoothness of the game obviously.
And in input lag wise, you can still
feel the input lag when turning the
mouse around and so on, but it it's not
obnoxious whatsoever. It's still 100%
playable, at least to me. And I'm very
picky when it comes to the input lag in
video games. So, uh I'm fine with this
experience. two times frame generation
is also a decent uh way to utilize FG in
this one instead of using like four
times MFG because with the baseline FPS
that we were getting 50 to 60 most of
the time with the LAA it means that
you're better off just using two times
instead of four times because four times
will introduce a ton of artifacting and
noise and just yeah it's going to be
really noticeable the imperfections in
the image whereas with two times FG it's
less noticeable. And it's still smooth.
Anyways, no problems with the image.
Maybe around her hair over here in this
section. You can see a little bit of
ghosting. Yep. And artifacting, but it's
minor, especially compared to the four
times stuff. If I use four times over
here, you can see, yeah, the hair looks
a bit worse. And there's also
artifacting around the trees.
Now, basically, I'd prefer to utilize
two times frame generation, even though
right now we're seeing 180 fps almost.
It just makes the image quality a little
bit more unstable. This way, for four
times frame generation, I really prefer
to have like 60 or 70 plus FPS as a
baseline before enabling MFG and not 50
to 60. Now it's Battlefield 2042 at
1080p resolution using the ultra
settings with no rate tracing or DLSS.
So native 1080p here. It still looks a
bit too soft because of that TAA
implementation of this game. It's not
really the best, but it's seeable I
guess. Uh and the FPS are actually quite
decent on the 5060 here. I still
expected a little bit higher, honestly.
Um but yeah, no complaints. It's going
to be a higher refresh rate experience.
It's super stable as well. doesn't
stutter one bit and it looks good
overall. Let's do the smoke effects
right here dropping us into the 90s and
80s at times. Worst case scenario. Uh
but again, yeah, this is stable, it's
smooth, it's playable. If you wanted to
get like 20 more FPS average, you could
play on high settings and get pretty
much the same visual fidelity. So, no
complaints in this
one. However, I wish it was a little bit
faster in in here. still a good
performance boost over like the 4060 for
example. Come on. My gosh. I'm really
looking forward to the next Battlefield
title. That's for sure. Okay. And it's
over now. It's one of my favorite games
that has come out this year. Kingdom
Come Deliverance 2 at 1080p using ultra
settings with the LSS4 Transformer model
native AA. So the LAA and this is it.
Pretty intensive this way, but it looks
beautiful. And there's virtually zero
pop-in issues on ultra settings compared
to high settings. So, it's pretty stable
experience here. You can enjoy the ultra
graphic settings, which aren't the
maximum, by the way. This still has the
experimental settings above it, which uh
are way too intensive. But yeah, this is
something that you couldn't really do on
an RTX 4060, the previous generation,
cuz that would just get you like 50 FPS
here, or 50 to 60 most of the time. And
this is 60 to 70 or 60 to 75 most of the
time. So a bit more stable, a bit more
gorgeous, but you know, it's not like a
huge generational leap. But once again,
it it's one of the bigger ones this
generation at the very least. I just
wish it had more V, but it's the same
talk every single time. Right. Next is
Doom: The Dark Ages at 1080p resolution
using the LAA and the ultra settings
here, but the textured pool size is set
to the minimum because if you increase
it a little bit, the VM goes over the
limit. We don't want that. And here we
go, guys. Let's destroy them. This is
awesome. Actually, this game is really
smooth as well. You can see the frame
time graph doesn't move whatsoever. And
even with all of these effects, doesn't
really drop too much, only into the
mid60s apparently. Maybe low 60s here
and there. But it is a pretty stable and
very enjoyable experience. Now, you
might want to play Doom with a high
refresh rate though because, well, it's
a firsterson shooter. It's very quick,
very fast-paced, you know. Let's go.
Come on. Goodbye, Bob. Tons of Bobs here
in this level. I love it. Forest to
kill, obviously. Come on. Goodbye, Bob.
Once again. Yes, sir. Look at that.
Beautiful 60 fps drop there. Okay, come
on. Let's kill this one. But even if it
does drop a little bit Oh, yes, it is
dropping right now into the 50s. Look at
that. With these effects from the gun,
very intensive stuff. You can always
utilize some frame generation. Let's try
it on two times. That goes slightly over
the VRM limit once again, but it should
be fine. It's only a few megabytes. Uh,
let's see how it does. Oh, yes. All
right. This game, for some reason, maybe
because it was made with frame
generation in mind, uh, it runs really
well with it, and there's basically no
input lag here. There is just a little
bit of it. If I'm being very picky, I I
might be able to notice, but it still
feels really responsive, even for a
firsterson shooter with frame
generation, which I usually hate. And it
still stays really stable above
basically 100 FPS right now. Uh although
the baseline was actually dropping from
60 as you saw. All right. Come on. There
it is. Yeah, this is awesome guys. I
mean it would be nicer if we could
increase that texture pool size
obviously, but textures still look
pretty decent. Pretty well optimized for
a rate race title and the 5060 does drop
just a little bit. Next up is GTA 5
enhanced but with the natural vision
enhanced mod at the same time. This is
really intensive guys. Let's go over the
settings. And we're playing at 1080p
resolution using the maximum settings
including rate tracing the LAA right
there and the normal depth of field
because they don't recommend anything
higher for the mod. And this way the
game looks absolutely fantastic. I
really like the look of NVE in this one
with the rate racing as well. It's very
intensive as you can see, but it's
actually staying above 60fps for the
most part. I already saw it dropping
into the 50s whenever you are inside of
buildings, you know. But whenever you
are out and about just playing the game,
having a lot of fun, driving cars
around, shooting people, exploding
things, which is really intensive as
well, but it doesn't drop from 60 fps
cuz it doesn't really drop too much from
what we're seeing right now. Uh, it's
it's a good experience here, you know.
Could it be better? Yes. Should it be
better on a 5060 tier GPU? I think so.
This graphics card should have been
faster. At least in this one, it doesn't
have VRM related problems. So, uh, at
least there's that. And by the way, if
you're wondering about the performance
of the game without the NVE mod, just
add like 10 to 15 frames per second. And
uh, that's what you'd get with the GTA 5
enhanced on maximum settings as well,
but without the mod, which is again
pretty intensive. Now, this is Jack's
Hail over here. Here it gets 60s70s a
little bit better than the 4060 as well
that I tried yesterday. Um that GPU was
consistently dropping into the 50s and
40s around here. Hello Jack. How you
going buddy? Everything all right? Oh
yes. Um and this one is staying into the
70s. So a decent bump in performance
there at least compared to other 50
series GPUs in their predecessors.
Right. This still drops from 60 FPS as
you can see there though. Uh, Bob, what
are you doing? Trying to run away from
me. Goodbye,
Bob. Um, but yeah, aside from a couple
of drops here and there in intensive
bushes and intensive interiors, it runs
really well. Next is a really intensive
title, Assassin's Creed Shadows at 1080p
using DA, so 100% resolution scale and
the high settings preset with a
rateracing GI set to the maximum as
well. This makes the game look really
pretty in my opinion. and the RTX 5060
can actually handle it somewhat if
you're fine with 30 to 40 FPS or like 40
plus in some other areas. It's okay of
an experience, but this is not how I'd
play this game. Instead, I would utilize
some frame generation because that makes
a big difference in this game and the
game was made with FG in mind. So,
enabling it even with these baseline FPS
which seem to be really low for frame
gen in this one. However, it works
extremely well in terms of input lag,
even with low FPS baseline. So, let's
enable that right away. Nvidia DLSS
here. I would also use this instead of
the LSS quality because quality LSS only
gave us around like 10 15 more FPS. Not
that big of a deal, and it wasn't enough
to improve things up into the 60s, you
know, it was 50 most of the time. Um,
but yeah, over here once again, input
lag is noticeable, but for a thirderson
game like this and for a game that was
built from the ground up with that frame
generation in mind, it's working
absolutely great, guys. And now it's
very smooth of an experience. VRAM is
enough with these settings as well. Now,
oh, Roach is actually here today. Last
time around, I called Roach a bunch of
times and he didn't show up. I don't
know what he was doing. Anyway, around
here, as you can see, dense forest area
only dropping to around the same values
as we saw inside of the city. And yeah,
it works really well. It doesn't run at
a lower resolution because of the LSS
quality. This is still the LAA after
all. And I I'm completely fine with
this. Look at how bad we got to make the
textures look in Horizon Forbidden West
for it to not run out of VRM on the
5060. A 5060. Where are you? Oh boy. I
mean, some textures do look nice, but
some other
textures, right? Let's go over the
settings here. I'm playing at 1080p
resolution using DA and the medium
textures with high settings preset
everywhere else. So, I first tried it on
high textures and high preset, and I was
getting 50 FPS, which drops into the 40s
sometimes with 16 GB of RAM usage. So
that means that it swapped a lot of
things into the RAM previously and also
the GPU was running at around 90 watts.
Clear indication that it was running out
of VRAMm. Now with these settings high
with medium textures, it's flawless
basically in terms of frame time graph.
It doesn't stutter whatsoever. Power
utilization is completely fine. So we're
not running out of VRAM at this point.
And uh it gets 70ish frames per second.
Usually, if you aren't running out of
VRAMm, increasing textures will only eat
about like two FPS or three maybe
maximum. But if you are running out of
VRAMm, we went from 50 to 60 plus all of
the
time, right? It's a big difference. It's
a shame, guys. It's a shame. But no, we
got to compromise because 8 gigs. Now
it's the finals. I got it at 1080p using
DA 100% resolution scale with the
Transformer model and the dynamic epic
RTX global illumination as well as the
epic settings. You saw it, right? Let's
go. So, the game is basically maxed out
and I really wanted to include the
finals here because it's a UE5 title,
but it runs so well, guys. I mean, like
we got games like Stalker 2, for
example, running like crap. I mean, in
general, you know, it has a lot of
stuttering and instab instability
issues. Yet, here we are playing the
finals, a multiplayer shooter. Great
graphics, by the way, with the epic
settings or maxed out settings here with
rate tracing as well. I usually don't
use rate tracing in it because it's a
multiplayer shooter, but you can use it
with a 5060. It runs absolutely fine.
Not as high refresh rate of an
experience as I'd like it to be, but I
mean, yeah, you can always drop the
settings down to low if you want to play
this
competitively. Come on. Oh boy, I saw
that rocket flying towards me. Oh boy.
I'm fine still. We got one. We got one.
Oh, I died with a grenade, I think.
Yeah, that death was definitely a
flashback from
2008, I think, with Call of Duty Modern
Warfare 2. Oh, good old days of Call of
Duty, guys. I loved that game so much.
And also this one. I mean, again, this
is basically a flawless experience in
UEI5. You can max out everything at
1080p with a 5060 card and it will run
flawlessly. Also, this Kyoto map is the
most intensive map in the game. So,
you'll get even higher FPS in other
maps. Come on. There we go. Another
couple of kills here. Hey, hello. Oh, he
had a shotgun,
bastard. Uh, but yeah, it runs pretty
well this one. Next up is Indiana Jones
and the Great Circle. This game really
likes VRAM. We're at 1080p resolution
using the Supreme settings preset. So
everything is maxed out aside from these
couple of settings here because it's the
texture pool size and shadow quality and
they consume a lot of VRAMm which we
don't have. Okay, the LAA is also being
utilized. Thankfully though, this game
still looks really good with the low
texture pool size enabled. And the major
issue that I have with it is not really
texture quality or even shadow quality
right now. But the thing that annoys me
the most in this one is the popping
issue because you saw it right away when
I started. Like this area is super super
noticeable. Look at those bushes there.
As you walk, the shadows just pop into
view or the objects just change forms
and it's really annoying. And uh there
is a very good fix for it and that's
enabling path tracing. But we don't have
path tracing here with this GPU cuz
that's reserved for 12 GB GPUs or more.
Yep. No, but there is a better fix in my
opinion. You just type R LOD scale 5,
press enter, and then it's fixed. We do
lose quite a bit of FPS. We went from
100 FPS to 85, so a 15% drop in
performance, but now you don't have any
annoying uh pop-in issues. I mean,
there's still a little bit sometimes
here and there, but it looks so much
better like this. It fixes those
problems. It still doesn't stutter or
whatever, and the performance is enough
to enjoy this title. The Elder Scrolls
4: Oblivion Remastered is next at 1080p
using high settings with Lumen hardware
rate racing turned off. It still uses
Lumen software rate tracing, which is on
low right now. DAA 50 to 60 FPS or 50 to
70 FPS is what you can expect most of
the time in Oblivion Remastered.
Thankfully, VRAMm is enough for these
settings. I tried enabling some rate
tracing or hardware rate tracing
actually on high and it was a bit of a
mess. It ran out of VRAM, but here,
yeah, 7.6 GB, but it's allocating at the
moment. Not too terrible. Stuttering
issues wise, there is the frame time
spike here and there, of course, because
it's UE5, but they've actually made it
much smoother since the game released.
But, uh, let's get outside of this
village here. Oh, and it started raining
as well. And, uh, I think, yep, we we
actually ran out of VRM.
Now, obviously, you can lower the
graphics settings and the textures here,
so it's not the end of the world, but a
new GPU should never need these many
compromises in my opinion, especially a
60 tier
GPU. Medium textures works fine, as you
can see, back into the 60s, back into
the power utilization that it should be
doing or consuming. Uh, and back to a
flatter frame time graph as
well. But what a shame, dude. Because,
you know, if we had like 12 GB of VM,
for example, we could have the texture
set to high, looking a little bit
better. We could enable, for example,
frame generation on top of it and make
it a really smooth
experience. But now we got to settle for
medium textures. And I'm not even sure
if it will run out of VRAM in just a
little bit because FG also consumes more
VRAM. It's certainly stuttering quite a
bit right now. Oh my, we're only getting
like 60. Oh yeah, it's starting to
stutter quite a lot, guys. This game's
broken as well.
So, let's move on. Okay, I can't quite
believe what my eyes are seeing at the
moment, guys. Black Myth Wukong is also
a UI5 title just like Oblivion. Uh, it
also has Lumen enabled by default, yet
it's only allocating 6 GB of VRAM at the
1080p resolution using high settings.
Over here, DLSS is being utilized, but
it's at 100%, so it's DA. Frame gen is
off. I don't know why it's in Chinese.
Okay. But it is turned off. And uh yeah,
apparently aside from the usual spikes
that you get from UE5, which is very
awful, it doesn't have a problem, guys,
cuz it it actually isn't running out of
VR and it's above 60 FPS most of the
time. Those traversal stutters are super
annoying cuz I've actually done the
benchmark run once already, but they're
still
there. Anyway, U5 shenanigans, my
friends. Uh yeah, as you can see, most
of the time though, it's going to be a
smooth experience. It's no insane
performance, right? It's nothing really
that impressive, but it works. And it's
1080p native high settings. So, there's
that. No path tracing, obviously. Should
not utilize that, right? And if you
wanted to make things smoother, frame
generation is there. And we got some
headroom there on the VRM as well. So,
let's try it. And uh this is yes I I
believe or
on. Oh, it's also four times frame
generation that is enables by default.
Interesting. I usually like two times
more with the kind of baseline FPS that
this GPU provides at 1080p resolution
cuz that means less ghosting and less
artifacting as well and a little bit
sharper of an image. But hey, I'm fine
with this. In terms of input lag, it's
really snappy actually still since the
FPS baseline were above 60. And uh it's
getting 200ish FPS sometimes. So no
major artifacting is happening either.
Yeah, this is fine, guys. It's a good
experience in Blackmith Wukong. And I
think I would actually enable frame
generation in this one for that smoother
result. And it seems like it gets rid of
the little frame time spikes, the micro
stutterings as well. So yeah, this is a
little bit of a surprise after Oblivion.
And it is conclusion time, my friends.
I'll still have more games running right
here as usual, while we talk a little
bit about the RTX
5060. Can I recommend this GPU? No. But
let's go over its positives first. It is
very power efficient. As you saw, you
can play pretty much everything at 1080p
resolution with decent frame rates,
although with a lot of compromises to
the textures because of those pesky 8
gigabyte. Anyway, you can't play them.
And it consumes very little power for
the performance it gives. And it's also
a very small GPU. I I like it actually.
Sometimes being small is all right, my
friends, and it can be a positive. Now,
the price to performance is actually
decent. I wish it was cheaper, of
course, and I wish it had more VRAM, cuz
that's very important. That's the reason
why I can't recommend this GPU in 2025.
I don't know what they're doing,
honestly, with the 5060 over here. If it
had 10 GB, it would still be a rough
sell, but I think 12 gigs is what this
GPU deserved to be a good buy or
recommendation. as it stands, there are
way too many compromises that you need
to make to your games if you want to
play AAA titles, of course. Um, and I
really don't like it. Not to mention
that rate racing consumes more VRAMm.
Frame generation also consumes more
VRAMm. And I mean, this is an RTX GPU
from latest generation, so those are
advertised features on this card. And it
still has 8 GB. And if the only things
that you needed to disable were like
rate tracing for example, I'd be okay
with it. But it's textures. Texture
quality is one of the most important
things in games to make them look
pretty. You can have some games uh
running at like low settings with ultra
textures and they'll still look good.
But here it's the opposite thing. You
have games running on ultra settings and
you have to set the textures down to low
or medium, making them look like
plastic. I hope that the next generation
brings something great. 6060 needs to at
least have 12 GB. And finally, just to
see how ridiculous 8 GB are in 2025.
Let's remember some old GPUs. GTX 1060
came out eight years a actually no nine
years ago. It's from 2016 and that had
six gigabytes of VRAM. So in 9 years we
got two more gigabytes on the 60 tier
card. Yeah. Doesn't sound very good,
does it? But even worse, guys, the RX
480 had an 8 GB model back in 2016 as
well. It was the GTX 1060's competitor.
And that GPU cost
$229 in 2016 and it already had 8 GB. So
again, why do we still have 8 GB GPUs in
2025, especially with games already on
the market that can definitely saturate
that amount of VRAM? It's insane.
Anyway, I'll catch you in the next one
very soon. As always, love you all.
Bye-bye.